there are five gadgets i use every
single day
and couldn't do my job
what's going on guys my name is david
thomage and welcome back to the channel
midweek i know it's weird to see my face
in the middle of the week
usually it's every monday however i
thought because i stuffed up and
accidentally published my video on a
tuesday instead of a monday
as i always do and it really upset me
i thought i'd try getting an extra quick
video this week
so today we're talking about my top five
gadgets for architects architecture
students
and designers of the like these are the
five gadgets i absolutely use
every single day and could not do my job
without
and would not do my job without honestly
it makes me a much much better designer
to have these tools at my disposal
so number one a smartphone with a triple
camera setup that means a main camera
lens a telephoto
and an ultra wide these three lenses are
phenomenal in capturing every single
detail that you might need on the site
as well as capturing
all the content for social media you
might need number two
we sit at our desks so long personally i
spend about 12 to 16 hours a day
behind a computer so it's critical that
you have a good mouse at your disposal
that isn't going to kill your wrists
now i've already snapped my left wrist
in the past so i don't want to get any
couple tunnel or anything of that sort
that's why i've invested in the logitech
mx master series
i've purchased the mouse and i'm now
looking to purchase the keyboard as well
however i haven't used that i haven't
tried it so i'm only
recommending the mouse today as an
essential gadget
number three this is almost inevitable
and you're not going to be able to avoid
it
a very very good laptop to be able to
run
all the programs that you might need
being revit archicad adobe suite
twin motion or anything of the sorts
you're going to need a good laptop
my laptop of choice is the surface
laptop 2
or the surface laptop 3 depending on how
much money you have at your disposal
i have a new video coming up early next
week with my top five
laptops for architects so make sure you
smash that subscribe button to stay
tuned for that however my personal
favorite and current device
is the surface laptop number four an
apple ipad and the apple pencil
i'm merging these two together because
they are required
to be used in conjunction now i use this
for taking notes during meetings
marking up drawings or even just
sketching out ideas
these two devices paired are a
phenomenal tool
in the architecture industry and finally
number five
is a very simple very cheap little
gadget that i use every day
it is a multi-port usb extender so in
mind personally i have a couple usb
ports an sd card slot and a micro sd
card slot
that's all i need for me to be able to
transfer all my data
very quickly across from devices anyway
that's all for me today guys
like i said very quick very short video
for midweek
just wanted to make sure that i'm still
popping up on your feed
and didn't mess up by not posting on a
monday i apologize for that but as
always
i will see you next monday